[Applause]  jumps are the prettiest thing that a  cheerleader can do and just one part can  mess it up  it's once i throw her i'm just like okay  that's it  i'm not scared anymore she's already up  there i got it  performing and taking the test is all  the same  i practice and practice and practice it  and i still don't feel as if i got it i  practice more  i feel like there is no reason to go  if you're not going to give it your all  i love it when the girls get so  frustrated to the point where they're  mad at themselves i just want to walk  away like it's all too much it's just  like no no no you can't quit like i'm  not going to let you give up because you  didn't let me give up there's always  more that you can do there's always  better  it's a rush at the same time it's just  like you got it you remember this like  you've done this before once we get into  set  then i'm like okay it's go time  [Applause]  you